Ich bin froh, dass ich dich kennengelernt habe.
Der Preis-Champ, nice. Wo hast du gekauft? Bei Amazon?
Ich hab jetzt meinen Refling unten drin.
Exzellent, jetzt verdiene ich Geld da dran, wenn ihr was kauft bei Amazon.
Wie? Bei Mediamarkt, das gehört da.
Er wird schon jetzt auch bei Amazon kaufen können.
Standardmäßig in den Dark Mode, ich weiß nicht...
Nein, die Noobs aus irgendwelchen Gründen mögen lieber Light Mode.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Guck mal, wir haben jetzt Impressum, YouTube und Twitter Links auch noch am Start.
Muss sein.
Aber das Beste hab ich euch noch gar nicht gezeigt.
Guck mal, die Stonks funktionieren jetzt.
Das ist der UVP.
Und das ist der... Guckt euch das an.
Der UVP ist 499 von der RTX 370.
Und gestern hat die gekostet 1153 im Durchschnitt.
Nicht schlimm, oder?
Nicht schön.
Irgendwo, irgendwo... Ich hab mir im Internet die UVPs rausgesucht.
Ja, hier, guck.
3070 499 und aktuell kostet sie fast so viel wie eine 3090.
Aber die Historie ist ganz gut.
Übrigens, die Historie hat noch kein Limit.
Der macht jetzt aktuell jeden Tag einen Tag dazu.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Das geht relativ schnell.
Weil das wird ja nicht in der Datenbank ausgelesen, wenn ihr eine Anfrage macht, sondern im Hintergrund.
Ab und zu wird ein Report generiert.
Aber... Ich muss das beschränken.
Irgendwie erst mal schaltmäßig auf, keine Ahnung, 7 Tage oder so.
3070 nicht mehr verfügbar.
Ja, Pepehands würde ich sagen.
Es kann sein, dass der mit dem Crawl nicht hinterherkommt.
Wir waren doch eben gerade bei Amazon.
Mist, hatte ich eben gerade Amazon-Link auf?
Da können wir nämlich gucken.
Amazon.
Nee, war dann nicht.
Ja, wenn er mit dem Crawl zu langsam ist...
Ach, übrigens, ihr könnt jetzt das Ding, das Fenster auch ein bisschen breiter machen.
Zum Beispiel bei der 3090 ist das ganz praktisch.
Aber seht ihr, wie nice responsive das alles ist?
Ist noch bei Amazon...
Der läuft manchmal in irgendwelche Blocks, dass die Seiten ihn nicht crawlen lassen oder so.
Ja, da kann ich nicht viel dran ändern.
Oder wir brauchen noch mehr CPU-Kerne.
16 reichen noch nicht.
Brauchen 24.
Ich brauche einen 16-Kerner, nur für den Crawler einfach.
Easy.
Ich weiß übrigens gar nicht so genau, was wir heute machen.
Ein bisschen nicht großartig kompliziert ist.
Genau, hier, massive responsiveness.
Oder ich mache zwei Crawler.
Die Idee ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ohne Mist, die Idee ist echt nicht verkehrt.
Ich mache zwei 8-Kern-Crawler.
Und teile die Shops auf.
Die Idee ist echt nicht schlecht, weil das skaliert.
Das scaled horizontal richtig.
Und die Basics haben wir gemacht.
Deswegen wissen wir, dass skalieren das Allerwichtigste ist.
Guck mal, anstatt dass ich einen 16-Kerner hole,
ich könnte auch einfach zwei 8-Kerner holen.
Das wäre schneller.
Das wäre schneller und es kostet das Gleiche.
Aber vier 4-Kerner sind teurer.
Äh, 4-Kerner, wo ist der 4-Kerner?
Da.
Vier 4-Kerner sind teurer.
Was ist denn 15 mal 4?
Naja, nicht wirklich, alles das Gleiche.
Vielleicht mache ich das.
Vielleicht hole ich wirklich davon und davon ein.
Äh, nicht davon und davon, davon und davon.
Zweimal den da.
Dann bin ich sogar ein bisschen billiger.
Und der eine crawlt, wie verrückt.
Pro Shop ein Kern.
Naja, so ungefähr läuft es dann darauf raus, ja.
Exzellent, Ladebalken, ist das nicht nice.
Nicht so geblendet, nicht so geblendet hier.
Wir können heute das Notification...
Also was mich viele Leute gefragt haben ist,
ob man nicht eine Notification-Grenze setzen kann.
Ich will nur eine Benachrichtigung,
wenn der Preis nicht höher als ist.
Das können wir tatsächlich mal machen.
Das können wir tatsächlich machen.
Das machen wir heute, würde ich sagen.
Wir machen hier einfach so einen Pop-Up.
Da kann man Maximumpreis eintragen und gut ist.
Aber das Geile ist, Leute,
der Scheiß skaliert wirklich ganz gut, ne.
Weil ich kann im Endeffekt
das Crawlen beliebig verteilen
auf unterschiedliche Server.
Wenn du pro Shop einen Kern verheizt,
der ist nicht sonderlich optimiert beim Crawlen.
Der macht eine Chromium-Instanz auf
und crawlt dann alle Shop-Seiten durch.
Parallel teilweise.
Stimmt, das fasst schon in D-Dos.
Ja, aber ich glaube, ich...
Aber nee, nee ist nicht.
Ich habe hier eingestellt,
dass er nur maximal alle eins bis zwei Minuten fragt.
Nee, das glaube ich.
Ich glaube, das mache ich.
Ich kaufe mir zwei 8-Kerner.
Der eine macht halt Crawling und Frontend
und der andere macht nur Crawling.
Der crawlt sich dann richtig schein ab.
Beim Street-Merchant kann man keine eigenen Produkte crawlen.
Doch, du musst nur die Konfig anpassen.
Wir haben ja gestern die 9600 hinzugefügt bei Alternate.
Sag mal, was ist denn hier eigentlich los?
Warum kostet es hier mal ganz kurz am 1. Januar UVP
und jetzt ist es von 1000 UVP auf 1600?
Was ist da los?
Ach ja, übrigens wisst ihr was auch nice ist.
Man kann jetzt hier überall drauf drücken,
wo man draufdrücken will
und kommt direkt zum Shop oder auch neuen Tab aufmachen.
Man muss nicht mehr auf dieses Ding da oben klicken.
Sieht viel besser aus, oder?
Der Preis-Champ ist relativ akkurat, doch?
Also was, wie sich...
Der Graf...
Ach so, das meinst du mit akkurat?
Nee, wenn er den Link zum Shop nicht drin hat,
dann gibt's das nicht.
Da hat man schon mal ein bisschen Verzögerung
und wenn der Link zum Shop bei 3070 nicht drin ist,
dann ist es halt jetzt erstmal nicht da.
Da kann man nichts machen.
Vielleicht geht das besser mit 2x80 CPU-Kern.
Wolltest du gestern nicht die Kugeln wegmachen?
Nee, das sieht man nicht gescheit.
Eigentlich müsste ich die Kugeln sogar
noch ein bisschen größer machen.
Der Graf gefällt mir auch noch nicht so wirklich schön,
wenn ich da ehrlich bin.
Der könnte zum Beispiel eh nicht so viele Zahlen einplanten.
Ich weiß nicht.
Geizhals ist nicht genauer.
Geizhals ist vor allem langsamer.
So.
Geizhals updatet, was weiß ich.
Ja, ey, Alter, nur weil du es jetzt
bei einem Beispiel gefunden hast, heißt es natürlich,
dass Geizhals das Beste ist, ja.
Ja, natürlich kann das sein, dass das aktualisiert ist.
Es kann auch durchaus sein, dass der Crawler
die Seite nicht drin hat.
Der Regel ist das viel schneller.
So.
Ja, ey, viel besser, ByteStrike.
Hätten die alle eine ordentliche AP, die man abfragen kann,
wäre das viel, viel besser.
Viel besser.
Also, als erst mal aufgeregt und jetzt wieder gut.
Null.
So, ich muss mal kurz Dark Reader anmachen.
Das blendet mich zu sehr.
Weg.
Nee, es kann im Einzelfall schon sein,
dass Geizhals aktueller ist.
Vielleicht haben die auch gerade vor 5 Minuten aktualisiert oder so.
Ah ja, das geht gerade übrigens nicht.
Ja, ist schon gut.
Ist schon gut.
Also.
Ja, ich überlege gerade, was kann man heute machen.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen das Notification-Ding.
Weil dann ist...
Übrigens, Leute, ich hatte massive, massive Idee.
Guck mal, es gibt doch, es gibt doch auf Twitch,
auf Twitch, zeige euch das mal.
Es gibt hier Stock-Checker.
Das habe ich euch schon mal gesagt.
Es gibt Leute, die machen nichts anderes,
wie den ganzen Tag...
Wie das was?
Ja, guck mal.
Die machen nichts anderes, wie den ganzen Tag.
Übrigens sieht das fast aus wie der gleiche Crawler,
den ich auch laufen habe.
Passt genauso.
Nur, dass der, nur, dass der irgendwie nur 4 Seiten oder so crawlt.
Ja, das sind irgendwie nur 4 Seiten und nur Kokona-Seiten.
Also, ihr wisst ja, was ich mir überlegt habe,
was wir machen könnten.
Ich mache mir, ich mache mir einen zweiten Account auf Twitch.
Und da mache ich einen Bot.
Wobei, ich weiß nicht, ob...
Ja, doch, doch, auf jeden Fall.
Da mache ich einen Bot.
Da programmiere ich einen Bot für.
Und dann kann man in Chat schreiben.
Keine Ahnung.
Bot RTX 3080 ab 900 Euro.
Dann fragt er dich nochmal, ob er es richtig verstanden hat.
Und dann schickt er dir eine Notification im Chat,
wenn es so weit ist.
Ist der Preis schon eine PWA?
Nee, aber das könnte man relativ einfach machen.
Also, auf iOS kannst du schon hinzufügen,
aber das bringt dir nichts,
weil iOS keine Notifications unterstützt.
Deswegen ist das ziemlich RIP.
Max, auf Twitch, warum soll der gebannt werden?
Das ist doch vollkommen legit.
Kann man doch machen.
Das ist doch vollkommen legitim, sowas zu machen.
Auf Twitch.
Guck mal hier.
Der Kerl macht das auch an euren Zuschauer.
Also, ist das schon erlaubt?
Was ist ein Timeout?
Wenn du aus dem Chat gekickt wirst für eine gewisse Zeit.
Zumindest auf Twitch.
Ansonsten ist ein Timeout,
wenn was nicht antwortet in der vorgegebenen Zeit.
Das ist ein Timeout.
So sieht es aus.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist noch keine PWA,
aber das könnte man eigentlich machen.
Auf iOS kannst du es hinzufügen,
aber auf iOS, was gibt es?
Leute, hat irgendeiner von euch eine Ahnung?
Wie findet ihr übrigens die Animation hier,
wenn man was anklickt, was nicht geht?
Wenn man was anklickt, was gerade nicht verfügbar ist.
Ist euch schon die Massive-Animation aufgefallen?
Das ist kein Overlay.
Das ist dann wirklich, wenn ihr was anklickt, was nicht da ist.
Wisst ihr, was man noch einplanten könnte,
wann es zuletzt gesehen wurde?
Kann man einplanten.
Ja, aber das mit der PWA ist relativ einfach.
Wird das was bringen, wenn man das als PWA
unter Android macht?
Kann man das jetzt nicht eh schon auch hinzu?
Wir probieren das jetzt einfach mal aus mit der PWA.
Dann kann man es quasi so als extra Anwendung hinzufügen.
Aber die Android-Notifications funktionieren eh nicht.
Was macht die Webseite Analytics?
Welche Analytics?
Also manchmal sind ein paar mehr Informationen auch nicht schlecht,
wenn man was fragt im Chat,
weil was macht die Webseite Analytics?
Google Analytics?
Oder meinst du, meine Seite, was die?
Die macht nix Analytics.
Die guckt nach, ob Hardware verfügbar ist.
Ach so, ja.
Was?
Ich check nix.
Entweder ist mein Hirn zu kaputt heute schon, oder?
Ob du das Analytics...
Ja, das habe ich eingebaut.
Oder wir das größer machen, das grafen durch einen Button machen.
Du meinst hier so ein maximales Button im...
So ein maximieren Button hier irgendwie drinnen?
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Hab ich ja mal aufgeschrieben.
Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Also gehen wir mal in die Git-Repo,
in das Preis-Champ-Repo.
Oh.
Update.
M.
Den Preis-Champ kannst du nicht fetschen.
Der ist jetzt nicht mehr erreichbar.
Der geht nur noch über Cloudflare.
Git-Remote-RM-Preis-Champ.
Deswegen kann ich heute auch nix pushen,
weil ich mir gar nicht die eigentliche Server-IP rüberkoppieren will.
Ja, das habe ich gelesen.
Das ist witzig.
Die...
Weil Flash eingestellt wurde, sind Züge stehen geblieben in China.
Top Bleeding-Edge-Technologie.
Flash in Zügen.
Warum hat man überhaupt Flash in Zügen?
Es gibt Sachen.
Die muss man nicht verstehen.
Omega-Lull, aber echt Omega-Lull.
Kennt ihr übrigens schon
eines der besten ZSH-Features?
Habt ihr gesehen?
Guckt mal.
Man muss einfach nur den Anfang
der Sachen eingeben, wo man hin will.
Und dann drückt man einmal Tab.
Und dann expandet er das Einzige, was da drauf passt.
Also sprich, ich weiß, dass ich nach Repos-Preis-Champ-Client-App will.
Bäm.
Das ist äußerst praktisch.
Klar, wenn es einen anderen Ordner gibt,
sobald es doppeldeutig ist, geht nicht.
Wieso nicht Amazon?
Es kann sein, dass...
Wir gucken mal, ob Amazon drinne ist.
Können wir mal ausprobieren?
Wo hab ich denn das hin?
Wenn es überhaupt drauf steht,
vielleicht liegt es auch daran,
dass der Crawler zu langsam crawlt.
Also wird doch Zeit für 2-8, Kerner.
Ich gucke mal.
Äh.
Moment, ich muss erst mal kurz gucken,
wo ich den Kram hab.
Repos, Street-Merchant.
Gucken wir mal.
Stores, Models, Amazon.
Schauen wir mal, Amazon.de.
Was ist das?
Eine 3070 oder was hast du?
Eine was, ne?
Was, eine 3070?
Ja, eine 3070.
Gucken wir mal.
3070 hat er drin.
Jetzt müssen wir nur mal gucken,
ob er die auch drin hat, die du da gepostet hast.
Und zwar brauchen wir mal hier die.
Preis-ID.
Nicht die Preis-ID.
Doch, die hat er.
Ähm, wahrscheinlich hat Amazon
einfach den Crawling-Speed ein bisschen runter,
runter, äh, dreht.
Der Preis-Champ ist immer noch ein 16-Kerner, ja.
Aber der lastet nicht 16 Kerner aus,
der timeoutet zu oft.
Ich mach den einfach auf 2-8 Kerner
und lass die Shops parallel laufen.
Also der müsste, der müsste demnächst
ready kommen hier wieder, die 3070.
Aber wahrscheinlich hat Amazon
einfach den, den, den,
den Crawling-Speed grad runter gemacht.
Ne, ich hab noch nichts umgedrückt.
Ist alles auf einem 16-Kerner.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen der Nachteil,
wenn du die Webseiten crawls.
Das kann halt auch mal,
kannst halt auch mal kurz gesperrt werden
oder verlangsamt werden oder sonst was.
Da machst du nix.
Okay, starten wir mal.
Das Feature gab's auch bis zu dem Stream nicht.
Ach so, du meinst Stream...
Naja.
Aber was willst du dahin machen?
Ich mein, das ist eigentlich die Idee.
Also wenn du ein besseres Eigen...
Symbol hast,
es ist ja eigentlich nicht wirklich der Graf.
Es ist hauptsächlich die Anzeige
für alle,
für alle, ähm,
verfügbaren Shops grade.
Also,
da fällt mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nix.
Was könnte man da,
was könnte man da für ein besseres Eigen machen?
Oder wie könnte man das besser...
Das ist immer gut, wenn die Leute da schreiben,
weil man kann sich da selbst
nicht so wirklich reinversetzen.
Was könnte man machen,
dass man checkt,
dass man hier draufklicken kann?
Außer, aber ich mein,
die drei Punkte sind ja eigentlich normal für mehr.
Könnte man da...
Ich mein, die Glocke ist klar.
Die Glocke ist für Notifications.
Das checkt glaub ich jeder.
Pfeile?
Okay, wartet mal.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Das Feld wird größer,
wenn man mit der Maus drüber geht.
Hover-Animation?
Ihr meint, dass man die ganze Box
klickbar machen sollte?
Das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Ich bin aber,
was CSS angeht,
da muss ich erstmal ein bisschen basteln.
Okay, probieren wir mal aus.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Können wir machen, können wir machen.
Komm.
Übrigens, wenn euch die Musik
im Loop auf den Sack geht,
müsst ihr Bescheid sagen,
aber ich finde die Poggers,
ich kann mich dabei
übrigens gut konzentrieren.
Aufpreis-Champ.
Date.
Achso.
Vielleicht muss ich das Backend
auch mal starten,
dann wird es auch funktionieren.
Aber seht ihr,
das ist ein bisschen komisch.
Das ist ein bisschen komisch.
Aber seht ihr,
wie das Laden funktioniert?
Huge.
Huge loading.
Ich mache jetzt hier unten
die Developer Tools auf,
dass ihr den Chat
die ganze Zeit seht.
Also die Seite weiter seht.
So, ist das Ding jetzt gestartet.
Wait a minute.
Warum braucht denn das 100% CPU-Last
schon wieder?
Was macht das da gerade?
CacWate.
Was macht das gerade
für Dinger wieder?
Das russische Botnetz
ist jetzt auch bei mir
auf der VM.
Ah, hier sind wir ja.
Ok, jetzt müssen wir erstmal warten,
bis wir irgendwas gefunden haben.
Nein, 50% CPU-Last,
ja, damit kann ich leben.
Versehen die Buttons mit RefLink
habe ich mittlerweile schon.
Ok, also.
Jetzt probieren wir das mal.
Ich mache mal,
was der Chat
vorgeschlagen hat.
Also wir gehen jetzt mal hier hin.
Ich warte mal,
bis was grün wird.
Er muss halt mal
irgendwas finden.
Das ist alles out of stock.
Wie viel Traffic
hat der Preis schon?
Oh boah, keine Ahnung.
Also bei Hetzner
so gut wie kein.
Weil bei Hetzner bezahlst du ja nur
den Outbound-Traffic
und da habe ich vielleicht
400 MB oder?
Ich glaube.
4 GB habe ich da, glaube ich.
4 GB habe ich verbraucht.
Inbound habe ich deutlich mehr,
aber juckt mich nicht,
kostet ja nichts.
Boah, ist alles jetzt auch
schön zentriert.
Ok, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, Chat.
Also, ihr meint nicht hier klicken,
sondern da klicken
auf den Alert.
Also, das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Das heißt, wenn man
nicht den Alert klickt,
wir machen das jetzt mal für,
für, für keine Ahnung,
für die rote.
Das kann man dann ändern.
Das sind meine lokalen Tests gewesen.
Das hat nichts zu sagen.
Das ist nicht wirklich was unter UVP.
Ich habe, ich habe nur Amazon
mit Reflinks hier drin, wenn Amazon ist.
Anderes Affiliate habe ich nicht.
Will ich auch nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich habe das jetzt
nicht primär gemacht zum,
zum ultra fett Geld verdienen.
Bisschen was.
Zumindest, zumindest, zumindest
die Serverkosten bezahlen wäre gut, ja.
Versehe die Buttons mit Reflinks.
Nee, das funktioniert nicht.
Dass es mit Reflinks funktioniert,
muss ja auf die Seite von Amazon
geleitet werden.
Also, man kann ja nicht einfach
einen Reflink einbauen,
der in den Reflink kurz hingeht,
Cookie macht und dann weiter
auf der Seite bleibt.
Das Funks glaube ich nicht.
Wie ist das eigentlich?
Kann man, kann man Amazon
Reflinks über, über Iframes verteilen?
Also, könnte ich da jetzt Amazon
in einem Iframe mit Reflink aufmachen
und das würde ein Reflink Cookie setzen?
Nee, oder?
So einfach kann es nicht sein.
Das kann nicht sein, dass das geht.
Dann werden alle Seiten voll
mit Amazon Iframes.
Nee, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Das ist, das glaube ich,
das wird nicht funktionieren.
Nee, das glaube ich nicht.
Alter, da muss die Cookies
gar nicht ins Hauptfenster geben.
Der muss bei Amazon
einfach nur setzen,
ist über meinen Link
draufgekommen.
Es muss gar kein,
vergiss Cookies,
Cookies sind egal.
Das muss einfach nur
bei Amazon hinterlegt werden,
der ist über meinen Reflink
draufgekommen.
Wenn das rauskommt,
wird es bestimmt geplockt.
Scheiße.
Das geht, das geht nicht.
Ich glaube, das geht nicht.
Das wäre wild,
das wäre echt komisch,
wenn das geht.
Ja, ja, genau.
Amazon merkt sich
den letzten Reflink
innerhalb von 48 Stunden.
Deswegen wäre es geil,
wenn es über ein Iframe ging.
Na ja, gut, wie dem auch so.
Also, wir machen das jetzt
erst mal anklickbar.
Sollen wir kurz
noch mal andere Musik?
Nee, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Du kannst kein
Video auf Amazon machen.
Das mag Amazon nicht.
Das ist dann Cross Origin
und das funktioniert nicht.
Das, das, das, das geht nicht.
Aber ein Iframe
könnte gehen.
Ist auch egal.
Ich will da gar
keine komischen Dinge machen.
Also, jetzt probieren wir das
mal aus, dass die Leute...
Guck mal.
Ah, Asus.
Asus Kegwayt.
Asus hat wieder
Windows Protection an.
Und Amazon
ist jetzt auch drinne.
Ist die das?
Chat, ist das die,
die jemand eben
vorgeschlagen hat?
Alter, 979, ey.
Oh!
Ich sehe da gerade
einen Bug.
einen...
Bug.
Ich glaube,
der filtert nicht
negative Preise raus.
Das können wir
mal schnell fixen.
Moment, Moment.
Das ist mega eklig,
wie ich das gemacht habe.
Das wollt ihr gar nicht wissen
mit dem Report.
Genau, hier können wir
das rausfiltern.
Das...
Genau, hier können wir
rausfiltern, dass Asus null hat.
Asus.
Also, können wir
irgendwie so was sagen.
Optimiert er eigentlich
mehrfache Wares?
Macht er bestimmt, oder?
Also, so doof ist er nicht.
Preise muss größer.
Alter, warum lecken das so?
Preise muss größer null sein.
Was für Messages
werden über MQTT verschickt?
Ich mache über MQTT
die Benachrichtigung,
welche Produkte verfügbar sind.
Ey, der Docker-Container
frisst mir ein bisschen
viel Leistung hier gerade.
Ja, Moment, das ist jetzt...
Das kann durchaus sein,
dass Asus nichts sieht.
Das ist jetzt auch bei mir lokal,
was ich hier laufen lasse.
Es kann sein,
dass Amazon mich gerade...
Der Amazon den Crawler
gerade ein bisschen geslout hat,
weil er zu viele Requests
gemacht hat.
Das kann schon sein.
Das ist nicht immer
so hundertprozentig.
Also, manchmal ist es bei
Geizhals tatsächlich besser,
weil Geizhals aktualisiert
zwar selten, aber Geizhals
hängt bei denen überall drinnen
und die haben halt immer so
exklusive Zugriff auf die Daten.
Die müssen so einen Scheiß
hier gar nicht machen.
Macht der Crawler Logs?
Nee, da schreibt nur Standard Out.
Aber ich schreibe jedes Produkt,
was er gefunden hat,
in die Datenbank.
Also, insofern habe ich da
schon einen Log.
Sollte er das jetzt nicht
eigentlich neu berechnen?
Ah!
Okay, Leute, es hat funktioniert.
Der Asus Fix ist raus.
Der Asus Fix hat funktioniert.
Guck mal.
Er ist jetzt mal
durchschnittlich 909.
Das kommt hin.
Hier kostet er 850.
Hier kostet er 950.
Der hat jetzt 909.
Das kommt hin.
Das ist so die Hälfte so.
Ich meine, man würde erwarten,
die Hälfte ist 900, aber
das rechnet er ja nicht so.
Da rechnet ja das und das zusammen
durch zwei in dem Fall.
Aber jetzt hat der Asus
rausgefiltert.
Das ist okay.
Jetzt funktioniert es.
Jetzt stimmt der Stonks-Graf auch.
Das ist wie Musik.
We Shop oder so ist das, glaube ich.
Okay, jetzt können wir endlich mal
das machen, was ich die ganze Zeit
machen will.
Also, ihr meint, wenn man hier
auf den Alert draufklickt.
Okay.
Also, warum habe ich das
Dots icon?
Ups, ich bin gar nicht da.
Dots.
Hier, das da.
Also sprich, wenn man auf das
ganze Ding draufklickt,
öffnen wir das.
Äh.
Soll das jetzt nicht
eigentlich funktionieren?
Hallo?
Mal reloaden.
Du hast mich damals auf...
Hallo, warum geht das nicht?
Was ist hier los?
Da wird kein Klick registriert.
Ich mache jetzt einfach Trick 17.
Ich mache jetzt noch ein
Diff drum.
Wobei, wir können hier den
Klick machen.
Auf dem Diff.
Funktioniert es nämlich.
Passt zumindest.
passt zumindest
ist das wirklich besser?
warum geht denn das hier nicht drauf?
es verwirrt mich voll
der Button da?
warum kommt hier kein Click Event raus?
okay probieren wir mal
wir rufen jetzt mal hier die Methode POG auf
machen wir jetzt mal hier reingucken ob das wirklich nicht funktioniert
console log 1
das juckt dir nicht
frontend fulltime, das kotzt mich immer so an das ganze zeug
und jetzt meint der ein hover da drüber
also erstmal müssen wir den click hinkriegen
der click funktioniert schon mal nicht richtig
machen wir mal ein extra diff drum vielleicht funktioniert er dann
jetzt funktioniert er okay
jetzt funktioniert er aber auch auf den titel na gut das ist ja nicht so wild wenn er auf den
titel auch funktioniert
warum hat der Alert selbst kein click event? was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
darf man Werbung für die Seite machen? ja klar
so und jetzt gehen wir hin sagen hier serious box
kann man das im css? kann ich custom elemente einfach so?
einfach so stylen?
habe ich noch nie gemacht glaube ich von außen
probieren wir mal aus
background tester einfach mal ausfüllen
das funktioniert natürlich nicht
font size
einfach mal gucken ob es funktioniert
das kann man so nicht stylen
wir können sagen css, ne scale
scale auf, wie ging das 1,1 oder so?
ne okay man kann die dinge an der stelle nicht stylen das ist natürlich doof
hover
ja gut dann gehen wir da rein
aber ich meine ich kann das diff nehmen, was nennen wir irgendwie? keine Ahnung
massive name was
alter ich kann ja immer container scale
ach transform scale ist es
transform
scale und dann so
das juckt es nicht
aber wir geben einfach dem diff da drum herum mal nen
ich bin verwirrt, wo sind wir?
da ist mein POG
POG diff alter
POGU diff
class
container
Moment
container ist schon vorbelegt das geht nicht
äh class
POG
das ist eigentlich convention oder muss man das machen den kram klein schreiben
jetzt hat es mit, guck mal jetzt funktioniert das mit dem scaling
so und jetzt geht mal was hover? ne wie, oh fuck alter meine css
hover
oder einfach nur so
0.5
wow
ah
lul
he doesn't know, he lacks critical information
so und jetzt meint ihr wenn da einer mit der maus drüber geht
ist er big brainiger und checkt es, dass man das anklicken kann
so jetzt machen wir noch cursor, cursor ist
was ist dieser komische hand, hand cursor, copy?
nee, hand
pointer, pointer ist das glaube ich
ok nice, nice
excellent exquisite
würde ich sagen
jetzt noch
transition all is out
kann man das, kann man das
hintereinander schreiben
oder
ok das is out funktioniert nicht
aber da gibt es auch hier, warte mal view, hover
ähm
transform, da gibt es auch gar
da gibt es auch garantiert was eingebautes
hover
da gibt es doch bestimmt irgendwas fertiges
ok was auch immer
machen wir es von hand
0.2
haben wir doch, ah nee
ach komm mal jetzt is ja in, is in und out
nee out isen tut es nicht, warum out is, aber ist es nicht out, leute
ach so die klasse ohne hover
seht ihr mal hier
wird Zeit, dass ich
css
meister auf mein
singprofile schreibe, auf mein linkedin profile schreibe
hey das is cool, das gefällt mir
was haben wir hier noch für andere
ey das is ein bisschen klein
findet ihr 0.5 gut oder ist 0.5 schon dicken zu groß?
das passt eigentlich oder, ist eigentlich ganz gut
aber leute den alternate link würde ich trotzdem hier anklickbar lassen
dass man oder den link dass man direkt auf die seite kommt
was du kannst cursor hover weg machen stimmt
stimmt
exellent
also so dass man direkt den shop anklicken kann
ist schon nicht verkehrt
ich hab ja auch so gemacht dass es im neuen tab aufgeht
man muss bei so webanwendungen immer auch an die kaknoobs denken, die gar keine ahnung haben
wie der kram funktioniert
so
also das haben wir das, das finde ich gut, das gefällt mir
da können wir die dots eigentlich weg machen
ich mach, kommentiere man nur aus
auch wenn das nicht best practice ist den kram dann auszukommentieren aber
wir machen ja keinen stream um hier irgendwie
die sache schön zu machen, wir machen ein stream dass die sache funktioniert
ey das ist cool, das gefällt mir, guck mal
das ist gut, das kann man auch auf dem smartphone viel einfacher anklicken
jetzt oder
guck mal das kann man auf dem smartphone jetzt auch viel einfacher antatschen
oh das, da müssen wir, da müssen wir gucken, das darf nicht aufgehen wenn man den
button drückt
das muss ich canceln wenn man den button drückt
das muss ich canceln, das ist aber eigentlich kein ding
da muss ich sagen click
stop
siehste und schon macht er das nimmer
das ist auch nice
ok das gefällt mir, so dann machen wir den nächsten vorschlag vom chat
was mich ein bisschen ärgert ist dass man das nicht
das click hier nicht direkt auf die box machen kann sondern dass ich so ein komisches
fake diff drum herum bauen muss
vielleicht soll ich es nicht class pock nennen, sondern keine ahnung, class hoffa, hoffa scale oder
ich
ne hoffa ist ein doof
das heißt jetzt einfach weiter pock
david hoffa hoff genau
so guck mal der, der, der blinkt aber auch sobald er hier was aktualisiert
das sollte ich vielleicht jetzt auch einen anderen effekt machen
guck der bounced nämlich auch wenn er was aktualisiert
äh vielleicht, vielleicht sollte ich jetzt hier einfach
anstatt an an an an anstatt zu bouncing
äh einfach hier ähm
invert machen oder so
äh ne wie ging das mit, äh invert wie ging das denn nochmal
äh nein
ich hab das, ich hab das doch irgendwo mit dem invert
ah bam, da hab ich sogar copy paste
so jetzt sollte er nämlich blinken wenn er, wenn er, wenn er was aktualisiert
schauen wir mal
wobei wir können, wir machen das anders
ich lass mal das blinken dass ich sehe was sache ist
und jetzt
machen wir
das inverten dabei und gucken ob er dann invertet
nochmal reloaden
oh ne
äh das ist übrigens der kommt lokal nicht hinterher gerade
ich hab den lokal, der läuft lokal mit nur einem cpu kern
das wird im leben nix mit nur einem cpu kern lokal
da kommt er nicht hinterher, da timeoutet einfach gnadenlos
ok komm jetzt irgendwas aktualisieren auf
irgendwas aktualisieren aber der hat gerade guck mal der hat gerade die ganzen
dinger ge, ge, ge, ge crawled schon
ich warte jetzt eigentlich nur drauf bis, bis er was aktualisiert
fake product in stock ja das kann ich machen
ich hab doch sogar irgendwann noch ne wildschleife hier
asus durna 3060 bam
ok jetzt haben wir fake product klatschen wir da rein ohne ende
ok jetzt können wir den
scale raus machen
jetzt macht, jetzt macht so wenn was
das sieht man nicht wirklich gut oder
aber das ist halt ne easy animation wo man
was passiert eigentlich wenn man invertet macht 120
wow
was ist, was 200
und 150
ok es, ne mehr geht nicht mehr geht nicht
ok das sieht man jetzt aber das sieht mega hässlich aus
richtig hässlich
kombiniere es doch mit bouncing ne ich wills nicht bouncing lassen weil das
bouncing hab ich jetzt schon fürs hoveren drüber das, das verwirrt dann
das verwirrt dann man kanns shakeen lassen oder so
ne warte mal css keyframe shake
gibts alle schon fertig shake keyframe animation easy
du siehst du einfach man muss einfach nur wissen
wo man, wo man copy pasten muss
ich muss es bounce in nennen weil das so ein bounce in heißt
bam oh das
das poggers guckt euch das mal an
das ist wie im casino alter
guck mal wie es shaket
wir können es doch einmal im kreis drehen lassen
das ist ich glaub das ist gar nicht so schlecht wenn es shaket
und guck mal wenn man jetzt hovert
während es shaket dann, dann, dann ist es dann ist es komplett am eskalieren
die glocke bewegt sich nicht
ja die ist ja auch absolut an der die ist aber auch ganz gut
dass die glocke sich nicht bewegt dann trifft man die wenigstens
es shaket aber bisschen viel oder
aber wenigstens erkennt man wenigstens erkennt man jetzt wo was, wo was updated
kannst du das ganze system einmal vorstellen
du meinst wie das frontend und backend funktioniert oder die seite die seite
kannst du dir selbst angucken
gehst du betapreischamp.org
scale ist nur 1,03 du meinst
du meinst beim hovern oder wo
wie alles funktioniert
ok das das das das ist mir ein bisschen zu heftig
kann man das nicht noch ein bisschen
bisschen weniger machen
30 raus machen was passiert dann
aber aber ganz ehrlich die leute sind so shakeen gewöhnt für aktualisierung
ok du meinst hover nur 0,3 du meinst das macht es jetzt wirklich aus von
von der unter vom unterschied her
also so ist es jetzt
0,3
ok leute was besser 0,3 0,5 ich sehe das als gar kein unterschied
aber aber es hat schon mal gelohnt es ist wirklich viel besser so wie der chat das
vorgeschlagen hat
es kommt auch noch vor
übrigens ist sogar ganz gut dass man auch den den reisen hier oben anklicken
kann
0,4 ok wir machen den kompromiss
wir machen den kompromiss
0,10 ist zu dick
euer also
vielleicht vielleicht sogar 0,0,7541
euer exzellent
0,5 ist ok
also 0
ok sehr gut
also wie alles funktioniert ja kann ich machen
oder dass am unteren rand eine progress bar einplanet ach nee
ich glaube ich glaube das ist
das ist schon ganz gut wie es jetzt ist
progress bar nee also wie es funktioniert ja kann ich mal kann ich
mal schnell erklären also
es gibt auf github einen
crawler für hardware shops
und zwar
den da
so
hab eigentlich github dark sim aktiviert gehabt weiß gar nicht warum das jetzt
aus ist aber wahrscheinlich weil die es ausgelockt hat
also es gibt einen crawler auf github street merchant das ding ist eine
node shares anwendung die unter der haupe chrome fernsteuert
sprich der startet im hintergrund 150 chrome prozesse
und crawlt die ganzen shops durch
und ich hab dazu ein webfront entgebastelt der unterstützt
unterschiedlichste notification varianten ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr wer es
wissen wollte aber ich erkläre es kurz der unterstützt sich notification
varianten
von discord bis telegram bis sonst was
aber der unterstützt auch reddis und mqtt
und wer kann mir bei meiner c sharp hausaufgabe helfen
mach mal schreibt die hausaufgabe mal in paste bin und poste das dann gucken
wir uns mal zusammen an
und schreibt adwupplos davor dass ich sehe ja der kann auch sms und all möglichen
scheiß
aber ich habe halt einen weg gesucht wie ich
wie ich von dem crawler quasi mal eine dotnet asp.net core anwendung
notification schicken kann
und habe ich mir gedacht weißt du was
ich mache einfach den mqtt server auf
mqtt net ich mache mqtt server auf
und habe den eingetragen
bei dem crawler als notification target
so und der crawler crawlt
und schickt mir dann im hintergrund sieht man ja auch immer habe ich die
bach ausgabe
schickt mir dann im hintergrund immer notifications wenn neue produkte da
sind
so dann schreibe ich das erstmal in der datenbank
das hat sein eigenen webserver dabei aber ich habe noch ein reverse proxy
davor
ähm
das schreibt er erstmal in der datenbank
und dann ist dir das frontend über websocket subscribt
und kriegt notifications raus gepusht
so ganz grob die erklärung ja
das sind Vue.js frontend
mit
viel gedöns
oh warum sind die stonks kaputt
oder warum sind die 3080 stonks kaputt
das ist das ist lokal
achso ja weil nur asus drin ist und die haben keine stonks
die haben ja auch keine stonks
äh chillfreak was willst du noch irgendwas anderes genauer wissen
das war jetzt so ganz grob die variante
und letztendlich
hat das ding das ist auch nur der sqlite datenbank
hat es der sqlite datenbank
über websocket ist das verbunden mit dem web frontend
und da zieht sich dir den ganzen kram draus
deswegen läuft das auch relativ geschwind
das heißt wenn du hier auf preischamp gehst
warum der preischamp selbst nicht der allerschnellste ist weil es vorher über cloudflare geht
nach dem ersten stream
war schon gleich der der russische
gekommene dedos am start
moment frag wo ist
wo ist mein gekommene emote ich sehs nicht genau
deswegen musste ichs hinter cloudflare packen
code auf github ja aber privat
das ist auch mega hässlich
vielleicht mach ichs aber noch public
so genau wo also wo ist die
wo ist dies die sharp house aufgabe zeig her
der name alter schon
stellung 69 mag ich
das
so hätte ich auch mit 14 heißen können
auf welchem server läuft
preischamp
auf einem 16 core hetzner cloudserver
muss noch schreiben blies warten ja ja keine hektik ich bin da noch weite da
ich kann ein visitor counter machen ich hab also ich hab selbst die statistik
ich hab selbst die statistik wieviel wissen da drauf sind
wie findet aber ich muss ja mal sagen
dass das ist ein richtig geiles easter egg das da ist das da ist sie im
oben schalten
ne das ist futify das ist kein tailwind
wie viele npm packages alter keine ahnung
milliarden dass es noch wenn du wenn du in unberin store macht bei da hast ja
schon das halbe internet geladen
ich guck mal man mal um ich guck mal wie viele packages das sind
wie sieht man das eigentlich
ja anlist vielleicht
kann man das jetzt einfach zählen
5.000
Ja was kreppte alter
Ja was kreppte
Alter ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen
5135 packages ist da auch sowas drin wie
Ort und even ane
Das sind nicht die sind an die event das sind nämlich die sinnlosesten rpm packages überhaupt halbe internet kommt wie viel gigabyte
Gucken wir mal
Nur nur 327 mb source code nur nur
Ach da sind die da sind dupplicates drin sind echt dupplicates
Dann weiß ich nicht wie man es besser zählt
Ich könnte ich könnte den juni irgendwie raus machen aber das funktioniert nicht so gescheit weil es komischen trees drinne sind
Meinst du den ja den nordmodules ls ok kann man auch machen
Ok sorry leute es sind nur 1043
Das ist schon richtig ist keine richtige anwendung wenn du nicht mindestens eigentlich unter 5000 dependencies und 5 gigabyte tut sich da nix
Die aktuelle netzwerkauslastung vom preis champ
Das geht nicht gerade kann ich hatte so ein grafana
grafana kraft dafür gemacht
Aber der geht gerade nicht weil ich habe cloudflare eingeschaltet und ich habe noch nicht eingestellt dass ich mein prometeus
Metriken collecten kann wieder über
Guck sie habe ich umgeschaltet das prometeus collecten geht nicht
Über cloudflare aktuell das kann stelle aber noch ein dass es geht es geht aber
Gerade geht es nicht ich habe übrigens vorher auch gelesen dass man über cloudflare ssh machen kann auf den server ach ja
128 prozent lauter
Aber so sah die netzwerkauslastung die ganze zeit aus also wenn du es genau wissen willst da hat sich jetzt ja nix großartig geändert
Network traffic
Network traffic hier also so gut wie nix
Also die packages wo ist der normale traffic ach hier network hier network network traffic
Also guck der hat
Received so ungefähr zehn bis fünfzehn megabit die sekunde und
Transmitted so 2,5 oder so 0,5 mit ein paar peeks drinnen
Wie wäre es mit einem schalter zwischen dark und white team an sich wollte ich das ursprünglich machen aber der chat hat mich auf die idee gebracht
Wir können doch einfach den kickstart für den schalter mit einem schalter zwischen dark und white team
Das ursprünglich machen aber der chat hat mich auf die idee gebracht wir können doch einfach den kickstart für verwenden
Jetzt kann man klicken das ist das finde ich geil das ist so secret das ist so secret die snapchat generation mark anwendung die kein außenstehender
versteht deswegen das ist top
So
Die 370 eigentlich mittlerweile mal wieder gekrappt worden
Ok also sie scharbe aus aufgabe paste bin zeigt mal her
Stonks berechnung
Also seine hausaufgabe ist eine bank gewährt ihren kunden bei einer festgeldanlage
Das war cool wenn so viele zinsen gebe easy da würde ich den 50 50k geben und hätte 2,75 warum gibt es aber nicht
Gewährt ihren kunden bei einer festgeldanlage folgende zinssätze pro jahr berechnen sie durch ein programm nicht muss das die scharbe sein
Na gut aber ok bei was brauchst du denn konkret hilfe ich war in die berechnung ist das eine aber
Dass das das programmieren ist ja das also wo wo brauchst du denn konkret hilfe
Das läuft wahrscheinlich auf eine typische übungsanwendung auf so nach dem motto
Geben sie geben sie ihr anlagebetrag ein
Und dann musst du einen e-mail anwenden
Anlagebetrag ein und dann musst du einen if machen und gucken
Ist es über
5000 und unter 10.000 über 10.000 oder 50.000 oder ist es über 50.000 und dann
Was 2,75 prozent davon ich habe keinen plan von irgendwas ok das ist schlecht
Gar keinen plan also das sind ungefähr das ist mal zehn zeilen sein
Außerdem sollte bank das wenn schon den kobold machen oder in fortran vielleicht noch hast du denn schon was probiert
In welchen was mich mal interessieren würde in welchem fach ist das
In welchem fach macht man sowas heutzutage Programmieren ok und welchem in welchem ja
Also welche klasse
ist das das wird mich echt interessieren weil
Bei uns gab es bei uns hat das keiner in der schule gemacht wir hatten wir hatten einen it lehrer in der schule der hat gemeint
Da muss die wörtvorlagen lila machen nur dann ist es gut
elfte
ok
Dann ist das ja nicht das erste mal auch dass du das
Siehst also ich werde sie jetzt nicht vor programmieren ich kann dir sagen es ist an sich nicht kompliziert das sind ungefähr 10 15 zeilen
Wenn du irgendwas konkret nicht auf die reihe
bringst
Da kannst du noch mal bescheid sagen wie gesagt ich habe dir grob gesagt was du machen musst du machst eine eingabe
was weiß ich
Anzulegen den betrag eingeben du passt das als int
Dann machst du ein if und wichtig ist darauf achten bei den ifs je nachdem welche reinfolge du das machst du musst gucken
if größer als
if kleiner 5000 if größer als 5000 kleiner als 10.000 und so weiter also musst du es richtig checken
Du könntest theoretisch auch neu ist die scharp features mit pattern matching und sonst was nehmen aber machen ist einfacher
du machst ein if
Und am ende machst du ein console right line drunter
Also das ist nicht nicht schwierig
So 10 15 zeilen oder so
Genau und dann musst du noch mal mal 2,5 2,75 oder so rechnen
Ja exzellent
Boah jetzt hat alles auf einmal aktualisiert leute
Also wir wollen ja noch kurz wir können kurz noch was anderes machen und zwar das haben wir schon mal gemacht das ist schon mal nice das gefällt mir
Dass man das anklicken kann das ist wirklich äußerst nice
Und das arsos nur den keck weight kriegt weil sie keinen preis haben ist auch gut
Alle anderen kriegen keck weh arsos kriegt keck weight
Mal 1,2 ja ja
Das stimmt oder erst mal durch 100 teilen
Ja das stimmt oder erst mal durch 100 teilen
Konnte man nicht machen durch 0, irgendwas war das nicht das gleiche
Na ja und
Jetzt hatte noch jemand im chat die idee
Hier so einen hier so ein vergrößerungs eike neben den graf zu machen das finde ich ist eigentlich das das probieren wir mal kurz aus
Wir mal kurz schauen ob das funktioniert sondern so ein expand eiken
Dass man erkennt dass man es größer machen kann
Vielleicht sollten preise unter dem ms ja ja das das mache ich auch das mache ich auch
Also ich habe das folgendermaßen vor ich muss mir ein paar
Passende emotes aussuchen so nach dem motto für in der nähe uvp weit runter
weit drüber und total verrückt so nach dem motto
Ein tag ein woche ein monat ein jahr ändern zu können ja das ist auch eine gute idee wir können es ja mal kurz prototypen dass wir
Sehen wie was machen könnte
Ablauen kann ich von hier haut von hier e grad nicht das können wir tatsächlich mal ausprobieren
Also das war erst mal so ein expand knopf gibt es dafür ein schönes eiken für
So was da arrow expand
Ob's ich bin im falschen
Jonks da wollen wir hin
V eiken mdi und dann war man so in so ein expand ich kann heute echt nicht mehr tippen so ein expand knopf
Genau also ein button müssen wir noch drum rum an
Eiken
So ok und jetzt machen wir das da auf die auf die gleiche zeile wie stonks oder
Und jetzt halt nur noch nach rechts wenn ich mir jetzt wenn ich mich kann mir uns verrecken nicht nicht merken wie man das
Macht ihr neben das x
Meinst du
Immer dem x okay probier mal
Stimmt neben dem x ist besser da hast du das das das kennen die leute von windows
Klaus
Ich bin jetzt in die zum den
N erscheißer
Wißt ihr was das coole ist jetzt kann man auf die toolbar klicken es kann man auf die toolbar klicken
Und auf das ding und es ist es ist dingstig hier
Vielleicht sollte ich das bei der toolbar jetzt ausschalten oder das ist doch sonst noch verwirrend
Das ist nice oder
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch das eiken ändern für maximiert zu minimiert je nachdem was das ist
Kannst du das night seem persistent gestalten das kann ich machen ja das ist easy
Wo haben wir das hier
Da muss das das man war das das das kann man beim reload machen ja das ok da braucht man eine methode das mache ich schnell
Merkt euch mal wo wir gerade stehen geblieben sind
Das mit dem poc brauchen wir überhaupt nicht mehr aber ich kann es umbenennen
Toggle
ihm können wir machen
So und jetzt machen wir das was wir da oben in dem in dem klick machen machen wir da unten
Was mir fehlt bei javascript dieses jump to function ich weiß mit typescript geht das und mit neuem view soll es angeblich auch funktionieren aber das ist noch view 2 noch kein view 3
Ich weiß mit type script geht das und mit neuem view soll es angeblich auch funktionieren aber das ist noch view 2 noch kein view 3
Aber das ist noch view 2 noch kein view 3
So, mal gucken, ob das an sich noch funktioniert.
Oh.
Keck wait.
Achso, Moment.
This.
Ja, aber der erkennt nicht, der erkennt nicht, dass das eine Funktion ist an der Stelle.
Der kann das Viewzeugs nicht parsen.
Okay, gut, dann speichern wir das jetzt also mal hier, äh, Local Storage, äh, nee, Local
Storage.
Set Item, Theme, äh, und dann hier, keine Ahnung, Dark oder so, warte mal, wie mach
ich denn das jetzt gescheit, dass der sich das merkt.
So, und jetzt muss ich so noch, jetzt muss ich das nur noch laden irgendwie, äh, kein
Current Theme ist, Set is Local Storage, Get Item, äh, genau, Dark, und dann, ja, okay,
ergibt das Sinn, was ich hier gemacht hab, ergibt, ergibt das, ergibt das irgendwie
Sinn, was ich da gebastelt hab?
Und jetzt müssen wir nur noch Current, nee, so, und jetzt machen wir das hier oben, äh,
anstatt, ups, äh, äh, äh, wo, Pog, ja, äh, View If, jetzt gucken wir einfach nach
If Dark, okay, das passt schon mal prinzipiell, ach, nee, im Moment, ich muss das in Mounted
machen, Moment, ich muss das in Mounted machen, vergess, vergess, ähm, äh, not Dark Theme
in Mounted, ich muss das ja laden, wenn, wenn die Anwendung geladen wird, danke schön
für den Sub, Rocky ist Schuki, exquisite, kann ich nämlich hier rauslassen, äh, ich
muss das in Mounted machen, wenn das gestartet wird, äh, Get Item Theme, das hätte, äh,
warum ist das so dumm und checkt das nicht, solltet ihr das nicht eigentlich kapieren,
hä, du hast oben ein Ausrufezeichen zu viel, na, das oben, das Ausrufezeichen ist da erst
mal, äh, nee, wo hab ich ein Ausrufezeichen zu viel, speichert er sich das überhaupt,
hä, das müsste doch jetzt funktionieren, warum geht das jetzt nicht, oben, wo, wo ist
er oben, äh, aah, lol, weh, da dran liegt's, what the fuck, hä, what the, bin ich jetzt
total, ja, du hast recht, stimmt, äh, und, wo war das da, und jetzt unter, index, nee,
local storage, false, oh, hab ich das falsch rum gemacht, ok, wenn's auf true steht, dann
lädt er, und wenn's auf false steht, hä, what the, der macht immer das gleiche, es
ist egal was da drin steht, oder auch nicht, warte mal, hab ich das falsch rum, alter so
einfache Sachen machen einen teilweise echt fertig, alter, ich bin glaub ich da zu dumm
für, what the fuck, wo ist das Problem, also das ist ja prinzipiell richtig was ich gemacht
hab, ich lade das beim seitenaufruf, ist false, ok, komm mal, es ist false, warum ist das,
warum ist das überhaupt, hä, warum macht das nen unterschied, kakwait, moment, ist
das ein text, ist das ein text, kann das sein, dass das nen, moment, das ist ein text,
ok, aber es kreppt, alles klar, ok, aber egal, es funktioniert jetzt, es funktioniert
jetzt, wir müssen übrigens nur noch den fall abfangen, wenn das hier gelöscht ist,
was macht er dann, genau, wenn es gelöscht ist, das müssen wir noch abfangen, wenn das
nicht, wenn das nicht vorhanden ist, ok, wenn das nicht vorhanden ist, was gibt, was gibt
das zurück, null, oh null, ok, also ich muss gucken, ob item ungleich null ist oder ungleich
false, what the fuck, logik, please, hilfe, oh ich bin verwirrt, was zum, also erstmal
kurz gucken, ob das funktioniert, so ungleich null, ungleich null funktioniert, ist schon
mal gut, genau, und jetzt, und jetzt muss ich nicht gucken, oder, jetzt muss ich hier
gucken, oder, ach du große, große kacke, ok, wenn das gleich null ist, dann geht das
schon mal da rein, das heißt, ich kann mich da eigentlich drauf verlassen, warum geht
das nicht, nein, das kann ich nicht gleich tun, weil das ein string ist, warum auch immer,
java script, ich weiß es nicht, ich wusste das so mal, wüsste das jetzt nicht, wüsste
das nicht eigentlich jetzt funktionieren, aber also das an sich geht, was ich gemacht
hab, oder, so true, false, reload, ok, das ist doch aber von der logik her passt es doch
eigentlich, wenn es null ist, also wenn es ungleich null ist, warte mal, wenn es, wenn
es null ist, dann soll es ein dark seam sein, nein, wenn es, das hab ich mal brain zu klein
für heute, genau, wenn es null ist, dann soll es ein white seam sein, so rum, genau, einfach
nur item gleich gleich true machen, ernsthaft, das reicht, stimmt, das müsste reichen, weil
im sonsten fall kackts immer ab, ah, yes, chat, chat wieder, way too smart der chat
heute wieder, die vielen IQ boosts haben was gebracht, warum, warum, kann mir mal irgendjemand
erklären, warum ist denn das ein bool, kein bool, ein string, was ist wenn ich so mache?
ok, geht auch, klar, ok, dann, ok, ich muss doch mal eine javascript-geschichte ausprobieren,
was passiert, wenn man, ich hab keine ahnung was beim javascript passiert, was passiert
da, ok, das geht nicht, ok, das von uns, alles klar, sehr gut, excellent, ok, nice, also
Leute, dark seam wird jetzt gespeichert, wir haben es geschafft, gibt es einen, wie mach
ich, ich push morgen, das ist das update, so, äh, wo waren wir gerade stehen geblieben,
wir haben jetzt das erweitert, genau, die buttons müssen wir da umtauschen, was gibt
es denn bei dem, bei dem, expand, also, gibt es einen expand und, und die, die, die expand,
die farben kannst du nicht ein bisschen dunkler machen, ne, warum, das passt doch, sieht doch
eigentlich ganz gut aus, ich müsste eher, ich müsste eher die, die schrift von den links
noch ein ticken heller machen, dass der kontrast besser passt, weil, weil die links sehen nicht
sonderlich gut aus, habt ihr gesehen, asus hat gewackelt gerade, wie sieht denn das wackeln
im dark seam aus, weil, passt, sieht gut aus, kappa 1, 2, 3, jo, aber kappa 1, 2, 3 ist
nur auf der main site, ne, also wenn ihr, wenn ihr auf den richtigen echten preisschamp
geht, dann ist kappa 1, 2, 3, wenn ihr auf beta preisschamp geht, dann geht alles, den
könnt ihr auch erreichen von euch, oh, guck mal, er hat, er hat wieder eine 6.900 am start,
bam, ne, das systemweite steam übernimmt es natürlich nicht, gamma niedriger vom diff,
du meinst von dem, hm, ich mein, wir können das mal ausprobieren, wartet mal, wir gehen
hier mal zur, zum alert und gehen mal hier in das grüne, ich sag einfach mal lighten
to, äh, die schrift, das muss einfach blauer werden, dedos, cloud, ganz cloudflare dedos
sind easy, das, das blau muss blauer werden, kann man, warte mal, was für eine, was für
eine farbe hat denn der link überhaupt, äh, hier, der hat gar keine color, wirklich, wirklich
besser ist es nicht, äh, kann man dem link gar keine color setzen, kann das sein, ok,
dann machen wir mal einen button draus, machen wir mal einen button draus, wenn, wenn der
link nicht geht, machen wir mal einen button draus, beim link kannst, beim button kannst
eine color setzen, äh, geht auch noch, so, übrigens hier, beste abfrage, ob reflink
oder nicht, au, vielleicht nicht ganz so optimal gelöst, ähm, wirklich gut, besser sieht
es jetzt nicht aus, blue, green, primary, ich glaube es war darken to, ah, ok, guck mal,
ok, das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt schon besser lesbar, oder, muss jetzt nur irgendwie den
button beibringen, dass der button nicht so, nicht so fett ist, der button ist zu fett,
mutify button, wie konnte man den button nochmal ohne, ohne render machen lassen, wer, wer,
wer kann sich eigentlich dieses ganze css, den ganze css crap merken, äh, play, das
geht irgendwie, aber das weiß ich doch aus dem kopf nicht, wie, man konnte, man kann
den button irgendwie sagen, dass der, dass der mal gefällig nicht so viel platz verwenden
soll, wobei, warte mal, verbindet das überhaupt so viel mehr platz, mach mal kurz nochmal
den link hin, ja, oh ne, ich kann nicht mehr rückgängig machen, but why, warum kann ich
immer rückgängig machen, ok, jetzt muss ich es nochmal machen, ok, ähm, text, padding
null, man konnte, man konnte das dem button in mutify irgendwie sagen, dass er das nicht
macht, aber, ich weiß jetzt grad echt nicht, und by the way, der text sieht jetzt auch
anders aus, das gefällt mir überhaupt nicht, das war vorher besser, das ist noch nicht
auf dem public repo, ne, kann ich nicht einfach den link die farbe ordentlich ändern, das
mit dem link war schon besser, ja, was wir jetzt machen, wir cheaten jetzt, leute, wir
cheaten jetzt, äh, color gleich, also wir hatten primary, darken 2, so und jetzt, color
ah, yes, ja, jetzt machen wir den link hin, oh, jetzt, inline style, beste, color, ha,
ok, sehr gut, exquisite, erkennt man jetzt besser als vorher, ne, hacker mindset, ok,
also jetzt haben wir den kram gemacht, also das popup haben wir jetzt hier, ich wollte,
gibt es das gegenteil von diesen expand arrows, gibt es das auch irgendwo, das wollte ich
eigentlich grad noch gucken, also es gibt expand und gibt es auch noch dee-pand oder
so, collapse, collapse, ah, sehr nice, gg eats, sabotage 2 monat, dankeschön für den
expand, ah, ne, da sind wir, expand, also jetzt haben wir hier den arrow am start, je,
jetzt muss ich da noch ein if, da muss ich noch ein if reinbauen jetzt, collapse, oh,
jetzt haben wir beides, alles klar, excellent, ha, seht ihr was, ist das nicht nice, warum
kann ich das jetzt eigentlich nicht, ups, warum konnte ich das grad mit escape nicht
verschließen, der button crappt einfach mal mein escape key, was ist mit dem button los,
anzeige ist raus, der crappt mein escape key, frontend 0w, was ist hier los, warum macht
der so dinger, add, click, stop, ok, warum, was soll das, warum macht der so was, warum,
ich mein ich kann das einfach hier überschreiben, aber das ist ja doch schon richtig
monat es da ich sowas überhaupt brauch, oh ne, click outside geht glaube noch, click
outside geht noch, alter warum geht mein escape key nicht, jebaited, der crappt mein escape
key und jetzt geht der escape key, das ist bestimmt ein bug, control c geht auch nicht,
ok, darf ich normalerweise control c, ne, war das problem auch schon wenn ichs über
die toolbar gemacht hab, wartet mal wenn ichs über die toolbar gemacht hab war das problem
dann auch schon, ne über die toolbar gehts, was ist das für ein scheiß, was ist hier
los, warum crappt der button mein, jaja so schlau war ich auch schon, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, skin PortIMON, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Du guckst es dir gefällt.
So Sachen ärgern mich immer.
Warum muss das so kaputt sein?
Vielleicht weil die Toolbar standardmäßig nicht focusable ist?
Naja gut, aber da soll die Toolbar keine Click-Events registrieren.
Wenn ich auf die Toolbar zurück klicke geht's nämlich.
Okay, wir machen jetzt Trick 17.
Sollte der Expand nicht auch in der Höhe größer werden?
Naja, der ist responsive, also sprich, der wird nur so groß wie er sein muss.
Haben wir irgendwas mit drei Sachen drinne jetzt zum testen gerade mal?
Mein Crawler kommt nämlich halt hinterher.
Also sprich, der wird dann größer, kleiner, weil es drei Stück in eine Reihe gehen.
Nee, das ist okay so, aber das ärgert mich schätze.
Retain, focus, focus und click.
Ha, okay, wir haben es gefixt Leute.
Wir haben es gefixt, ich weiß nicht warum, aber wir haben es gefixt.
Ich weiß nicht, ich sage kein Blasen Schimmer warum, aber es geht.
Was ist wenn ich da jetzt sage, false, dann wieder kaputt, dann ist es kaputt.
Alles klar, also wir haben es gefixt, weiß zwar nicht genau was der für Schmerzen hat,
aber alles gut.
Sehr schön, also das war jetzt ja reine Optik im Endeffekt, so jetzt machen wir das
aus der Toolbar wieder raus da oben.
Ah yes, das gefällt mir.
Das gefällt mir, okay, weiter im Text.
Was war das nächste, Chat was hattet ihr noch vorgeschlagen, ich habe die Hälfte schon
wieder vergessen.
Android Notifications kann ich gerade nicht ausprobieren, ich weiß, dass die nicht funktionieren.
Android Notifications sind kaputt, weil Android und andere Notifications AP verwendet als
der Browser, aber Android funktioniert prinzipiell, nur iOS funktioniert nicht.
Gibt es irgendwie eine Möglichkeit iOS Push Notifications mit einer PWA zu machen, ich
glaube das ist nicht möglich aktuell.
Genau, den Notification Popup wollten wir machen, ja genau, der Sache nehmen wir uns
jetzt nochmal kurz an, dass man hier den Maximalpreis einstellen kann.
Ab wann man Notificated werden will, also für iOS Notifications muss man zwingende
Native App machen, im Zweifelsfall ohne Scheiß, wenn das Ding wirklich so gut benutzt wird
und es in Android und so alles funktioniert, da mache ich so eine Konverter App draus,
die einfach eine iOS App draus zusammenpackt.
Ich weiß nicht wie man das am besten konvertert dazu, aber kann nicht so schwierig sein.
Dann macht sich der Max einen Apple Developer Account und reicht seine erste App für den
App Store ein, dann wird der Preis Champion weltweit der Hit, ich sage es euch, weltweit
auch wenn es nur Deutschland kann, ist egal.
Ich weiß nicht was das kostet im App Store, keine Ahnung.
Ja, eine PWA kann man da easy draus machen, das kann man sogar machen, PWA ist total einfach,
aber ich weiß aus dem Kopf nicht, man muss nur ein Manifest erstellen, das ist alles,
man muss nur ein Manifest erstellen und schon funktioniert es.
PWA Manifest Generator, das ist total, Alter, ich hasse es wenn der Kram so aufploppt.
Apple App Name hier, Preis Champ, wobei das kann doch, View CLI PWA, das geht doch hier
garantiert auch da drüber irgendwie.
Ok, jetzt machen wir erstmal einen Commit, Git Commit A-M, was haben wir denn gemacht,
Fine Tuning, Auto Use PWA Plugin, ah stimmt, das gibt es nämlich schon.
Shared PWA, yep, yep, yep cock, das machen wir jetzt, es haut die vor, was ist eine PWA,
ich zeige dir das mal am Beispiel PWA Firefox Example, die hatten doch eine Demo, wo ist
die Demo, die gab es doch hier irgendwo.
Die hat noch eine ganz easy Demo, wo man das gesehen hat, wie es aussieht, eine PWA ist
im Prinzip ein Browser nur in einem eigenen Fenster, Ach Examples, genau das suche ich,
so guck, das ist eine PWA, ich meine die hat nur Firefox Bilder und du siehst hier, ach
Moment, der kann das gar nicht, kann das der Desktop Firefox nicht, der Desktop Chrome
kann es auf jeden Fall, so ich mach so den Desktop Chrome auf, das ist eigentlich eher
eine Smartphone Geschichte.
Guck, jetzt gibt es hier oben ein Button installieren, warum kriegt Firefox da keine, also das ist
eigentlich eine Smartphone Geschichte, dann hast du das Ding in deinem Homescreen als
eigene Anwendung, obwohl es eigentlich nur noch die Webseite ist, aber Chrome Desktop
kann es auch, du kriegst dann hier oben so einen Installer Button, dann sagst du ok,
ich möchte die PWA installieren, dann hast du hier quasi so eine Standalone Anwendung,
obwohl es im Endeffekt nur die Webseite ist, das ist halt für Smartphones gut, wenn man
keine App Store App machen will, Firefox sackt einfach die letzten Jahre über, wir machen
eine PWA und dann könnte ich das morgen ausprobieren unter Android, also wie geht das jetzt hier,
also Service Worker geht mir auf den Sack, dass der Standalone nicht was cached, den
will ich nicht haben, Manifest Jason brauchen wir, das geht doch bestimmt noch PWA ohne
Service Worker, Service Worker sind übelst nervig, dann Refresh der Cache nicht und solche
Dinger, wir können einfach die App von Hand anlegen oder, wir brauchen auch gar kein
PWA Plugin, Manifest Jason im Public Folder machen wir jetzt einfach, die Public Folder,
Manifest Jason, Namepreischamp.org, Namepreischamp, Icons, Android Chrome, Moment wir haben nur
ein Android Chrome, wir haben bloß ein Android Chrome 500x500, das haben wir nicht, direkt
in Public drin, oder muss man, Moment muss man hier auch, muss man hier Public davor
machen, da bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher, Start URL Index, Display Standalone, was
gibt es denn da noch, was kann man da alles machen, Display Manifest Jason, Display Standalone,
Fullscreen es wird der gesamte verfügbare Anzeigebereich verwendet, ich gehe mal davon
aus, dass außer Standalone überhaupt nichts funktioniert richtig, ok, so jetzt haben wir
eine Pogas PWA am Start, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das schon funzt, gucken wir mal, probier
das so im Chrome aus, ist nicht installierbar, achso, ok das funktioniert auch nicht, ach
das muss ich noch einbinden, Moment ich muss das ja noch irgendwo in meinem Index.js einbinden,
Index HTML Manifest, könnte das was für dich sein, View Native IO, sofern ich einfach
was konvertieren kann auf jeden Fall, solange ich einfach meinen Crempel konvertieren kann
und gut ist, Add a Web Manifest, ja zeig wie es geht, ja da, doch noch man braucht zwingend
HTTPS, zumindest auf Android, stimmt das kann ich ja lokal gar nicht ausprobieren, vielleicht
geht es aber auf Localhost, vielleicht ist er so nett und lässt mich auf Localhost ausprobieren,
so, Index, so Manifest, bin ich jetzt sicher, braucht man Public oder nicht, Manifest, ok
Manifest, warte ich fahre schonmal die falsche Seite, also es ist Public, alles jetzt geladen,
Manifest, hä, alter wie ist denn die Url richtig, ok ich gucke einfach mal was das Bild für
ein Url hat, dann sehe ich es ja, im Image, wait a minute, keck wait, warum ist das, ist
das unter Image, Image, ok jetzt bin ich echt verwirrt, wie kann ich jetzt da drauf
verlinken, wo ist es denn, achso ich habe ja auch Manifest.json, einfach so, was ist
mein richtiger Pfad, ah da ist es doch, ok mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert, das geht
nicht, aber lässt mich das der Chrome-Lokal jetzt machen, ok das muss ich dann mal ausprobieren
da wo ich HTTPS am Start habe, oder muss das Ding Manifest heißen, nee das kann auch Manifest.json
heißen, das ist eigentlich egal, naja, nee ich will mir jetzt kein Self-Sign-Zert machen,
weiße euch das machen können, habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf, erfindet das aber mal
zumindest schon, aber dann ist das auf jeden Fall unter Image, ich gehe mal davon aus
das geht nur über HTTPS, hast du noch Kontakt zum Frisör, ich habe den Frisör heute gehostet
auf Twitch, ich bin auch gerade nicht verwirrt, was will das Ding eines von mir, ich bin auch
gerade nicht verwirrt, was will das Ding eines von mir, warum lädt das auf einmal jetzt irgendwelche
Chrome-Android-Bilder, hat das damit was zu tun, tatsächlich, macht nur deshalb, woher
weiß ich denn wo das Icon ist, ja das ist ein Icon für den Homescreen ok, aber woher
weiß ich denn wo das Icon ist, ich meine die Bilder die ich hier habe, die heißen ganz
merkwürdig Wupp Breim Blablub, wie verlinke ich das denn jetzt in meinem Manifest richtig,
ok das ist mir zu, das ist mir jetzt gerade echt zu hoch, kann man da Assets, Moment
wie habe ich das denn, wie habe ich das Bild beim Preis-Champ Wupp Pock, Assets Wupp Pock
habe ich da genommen, also machen wir hier auch Assets, Android, Chrome, wer ist da zu
Low-Brain dafür, naja gut, das muss ich mir nochmal angucken, aber das funktioniert nicht
an der Stelle, zumal, aber das hat mit Image ist schon, ach Moment Image-Icons muss ich
da vielleicht raus machen, ok, was auch immer, da ist so viel Magic immer dabei, wo du gar
nicht mehr durchblickst, wo überhaupt irgendwas ist, Alter, warum ist das so, so viel Magic
da überall, nö juckt den nicht, juckt den überhaupt nicht, was witzig ist wenn ich
das weglasse, wenn ich das weglasse dann meint er zumindest das es ein Bild ist, aber
er findet nix, weil er ja eigentlich, ist das, heißt das denn Android minus Chrome, minus
512, das heißt doch genauso, das ist das, das ist das Android, das Android Dings hier,
Fuff-Icon, ok, das wäre jetzt echt zu blöd gerade, da blinke ich nicht durch, das ist
mir zu hoch, aber das ist echt krass wie viel Magic da im Hintergrund am Start ist,
das findet er nicht, Alter was, ne ne ne, das wäre jetzt zu hoch, ne Public davor habe
ich schon probiert, Punkt Slash, hä meinst du wirklich, ne das kann eigentlich nix damit
zu tun haben, sollte doch standardmäßig schon sein, nope, findet er nicht, aber der sollte
mir auch so anbieten das zu installieren, macht er nicht, kann man Files Browsen, Public,
geht nicht, ja gut ich habe keine Ahnung was da der richtige Pfad für ist, ja ob das
überhaupt funktioniert weiß ich überhaupt nicht, ne, es kann durchaus sein das es auch
nicht, dass es auch nicht funktioniert, ne funktioniert auch nicht, das mit Index wird
wahrscheinlich auch nicht funktionieren, ok das muss ich mir mal in Ruhe angucken, ok
wisst ihr was wir machen, ich komm bitte nochmal kurz, hängen wir mal an, und jetzt mache
ich mal View at PWA, mal gucken, mal gucken, was der an Beispiel Code da für mich macht
jetzt, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, was macht der da für Beispiel Code für mich jetzt,
da sehen wir mal wie es richtig geht, das wird später teilweise zum Webroot Folder,
weil Webpack im Hintergrund übelst viel Magic macht, ne da validiert das das Cert, ich glaube
nicht, dass der Dev Server der richtige Cert hat, wobei doch das kann tatsächlich sein,
dass es bei Local Host getrusted wird, das probiere ich jetzt mal sogar aus, Webpack ist
richtig Paynes Champ, ok jetzt haben wir hier ein Sides Manifest, hat er das jetzt im Index
noch doppelt gemacht, ne da ist nur mein Manifest drin, ok das schmeiß ich jetzt raus, aber
jetzt haben wir auf einmal, jetzt haben wir auf einmal hier nen, what the fuck, was ist
das Ding so eingebunden, ok, hit reset, ich, ich, Leute, ich werde den Kram jetzt einfach
nochmal kurz wegschmeißen, warum ist der Kram noch da, achso, ach jetzt hat er nen Image
da drunter gemacht oder was, what the, alter, hör mir auf, das gucke ich mir morgen an,
da ist mein Prane heute definitiv zu low für, so alles gesettet, da ist mein Prane zu low
für, das mache ich auch wieder raus, warum ist das überhaupt noch da, warum ist das überhaupt
noch da, hab ich das aus versehen mit committed vorhin, ah ok, ok, reicht, weg, weg damit,
alter, ne, ne, ne, ne, ok, da würde ich sagen, das reicht jetzt auch, also mit PWA marsch
morgen oder so, das ist mir jetzt zu undurchsichtig, das können wir übrigens weg machen, das auch
weg, alter, die Pogchamps sieht einer schlimmer aus als der andere aus jeden Tag, so, also
Leute, das andere kriegen wir glaube ich nicht mal richtig gebacken, also was ich jetzt eigentlich
mal machen wollte ist folgendes, dort wo dieses Notification Icon ist, also da, wo dieses
Bell Icon ist, da wollte ich eigentlich ein Menü machen, was rauspoppt, wenn man drauf
klickt, also im Endeffekt, anstatt das da, view menu, äh, mein, wie ging das jetzt,
beautify menu, seix, was los, WSL, ja, WSL, naja, so scheiße, also wenn man keine andere
Möglichkeit hat, ist WSL schon ganz gut, menu, ja, wenn man keine andere Chance hat, dann
bleibt ja, gut, bleibt ja auch nichts anderes übrig, ne, außer den Kram zu verwenden, aber
so mit einem native linux ist das, wow, schon etwas angenehmer, so, und jetzt machen wir
das Menü, calculate, was habe ich falsch gemacht, oder was habe ich falsch copy pasted, irgendwas
habe ich falsch copy pasted, bin ich ganz sicher, was, was, was habe ich, was habe ich falsch
gemacht, dass das jetzt nicht geht, also man kann anscheinend das Icon da nicht einfach
rein pasten, achso, weil es ein Button sein muss, muss ein Button sein, ok, ich muss das
in den Button copy pasten, die Timeout Belohnung, du kriegst ein Timeout, wenn du Punkte rein
haust, ja, ob das jetzt eine Belohnung ist oder nicht, das musst du dir, das musst du
dir selbst überlegen, mach das, ach guck mal, hä, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht, Scam
Master, Alter, das Menü geht nicht, warum geht das Menü nicht, hier funktioniert es
mit CACW, ach Moment, ich muss das Menü da reinschreiben, da muss es weg und da muss
es rein, ne, jetzt klappt CACW auf, genau, sehr gut, sehr gut, so, color, brauchen wir
nicht, transparent oder keine color, Icon, ja, guck mal, und jetzt kriegen wir schon einen
Dropdown, wenn man da draufklickt, nice, und da müssen wir jetzt eine Karte rein machen,
immerhin, man sieht schon mal, dass man da jetzt einen Dropdown kriegt, in die Karte
machen wir einen Switch, wow, click, wie kann man dem sagen, dass das bei click, click, close
on click, false, false, ne, close on, ne, nicht close on click, false, close on content
click, false, wunderbar, guck mal, jetzt habe ich einen Popup und da kann ich jetzt alles
mögliche rein machen für, ab welchem Preis man das haben will, so, beautify, Texts, Field
oder Textinput, guck mal Leute, es gibt ja Leute, die sagen, sie müssen Wim ihre Finger
permanent auf der Homerow haben, weil nur so können sie am schnellsten tippen und nur
so ist das niedrigste Brainlag Latency richtig, das besteht im Endeffekt aus 90% Google gucken,
wie willst du, was bringt mir die ganze Zeit meine Finger auf der Homerow, wenn ich laufend
die Maus brauche für den Browser, total overrated, she baited, ja, das darf er haben, so was da,
Texts, Field, Texts, Field, genau, ok, das sieht jetzt zwar noch nicht sonderlich gut
aus, aber das kriegen wir gleich hin, also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall schon mal kein
Label, so, wir brauchen eine Überschrift, wir brauchen eine Überschrift, sowas in
der Richtung wie MaxPrice oder so, MaxPrice, so, und da kann man jetzt eintippen, was wir
für MaxPrice haben will, also das wird dann mit dem Button einen ausgeplendet, das muss
ich mir noch mal überlegen, wie ich das mache, gescheit, SeniorGoogler, größter SeniorDevel
aber eindeutig, wer richtig googeln kann hat gewonnen, MaxPrice, sowas mal in die Überschrift,
in den Switch, das in einen Diff rein, falls das geht, ehh, ok, ist schissen aus, aber
sehen wir jetzt, anderweitig, nee, ich fixen, also ich baue jetzt nur mal von der Idee auf,
ich mach mal kurz Lightseam an, ok, das soll einen ausgeplendet werden mit dem Button und
jetzt brauchen wir unten noch ein Close, Close und ein Hickchen, ein Hickchen Button brauchen
wir unten noch, Hickchen und X brauchen wir noch als Button unten, Decart Actions, heißt
das glaube ich, Decart Actions, die Leute sind absolut Qt Chat am Start, der Alarm müsste
auch wieder als Cookie gespeichert, das macht er schon, der Alarm wird schon als Cookie gespeichert,
also wenn du Refresh ist das da, das macht er jetzt schon, oh guck mal, ich hab das aus
dem Kopf richtig geschrieben, Poggers, so Wboot, Close und ok, gibt es jetzt einen Button
unten dran, das sieht doch schon mal ganz brauchbar aus, Darkseam vielleicht ein bisschen
verbesserungswürdig, so das machen wir jetzt nicht Close, sondern wir machen ein Icon rein,
was Close ist, MDE, Close, was gibt es denn da für schöne Icons, für Close und Accept,
heißen die vielleicht Accept sogar, ach Moment, muss man ja, ok Close ist ein X, gibt es
schon mal, wir machen da lieber einen Button drum, sieht besser aus, so und jetzt gibt
es Accept, gibt es sowieso ein Accept, so ein Hickchen oder so, ok, ne das wäre zu
einfach wenn die Dinger so heißen, was gibt es denn da, Accept, ich brauch so ein Hickchen
für alles klar, speichern, ok, Save, ne ich will kein, ich will so ein Hickchen, Check,
sowas hier, Check, Affirm, gibt es das, aber Check, Check ist gut, so das ist Check, was
für ein Dark Mode Adan hast du, das ist in der Seite eingebaut, aber ich hab, ich hab
auch sonst noch nicht Darkreader, gut, das ist auch eigentlich schon mal ein ganz gutes
Popup oder, du klickst jetzt auf Notifications, dann kannst du auswählen ob du einen Preis
festlegen willst oder nicht und drückst einfach ok, ok wir machen jetzt noch ein Label, Label,
Max, Preis, ja so ist es viel besser, so und wenn das nicht gesetzt ist dann ist dann einfach
auch kein Textfield drunter, so da ist kein Textfield drunter und dann sag ich jetzt einfach
ok und dann werde ich notifiziert, versteht man das, also würde man, also mal angenommen
ihr klickt hier drauf, ist euch dann klar, dass wenn ihr hier nochmal draufklickt, dass
dann die Notifications an sind, kapiert man das, eher nicht, ich glaube nämlich auch
die Kacknoobs kapieren das nicht, aber wie willst du das anders machen, na gut ohne Kontext,
na gut da machen wir eine Überschrift, da machen wir eine Überschrift Leute, wir machen
eine Überschrift, Benachrichtigung, Benachrichtigung, was Glockeneigen verändern, nee warum, die
Glocke für Alarm ist doch wunderbar, ja so ja by the way das passiert schon, also wenn
du hier auf ok klickst und dann das wirklich speichert dann wird die Glocke auch anders,
jaja das kann ich gerade nochmal machen, Moment, Toggle Notification muss ich machen, ich
bin gerade gar nicht sicher wo wir hier gelandet sind, der Klick geht einfach nicht durch
oder, Moment was habe ich denn hier gemacht, ich habe da ein Button mit einem Menü drinnen,
das ist doch nicht so gedacht, wartet mal, wartet mal, ich glaube ich habe mich hier
sinnlos vercopy pasted vorhand, oder auch nicht, Moment, Moment, jaja,
ich glaube ich habe mich da sinnlos vercopy pasted, das muss da oben rein, das Klick muss
weg, ja, ja jetzt ist besser, ich weiß nicht was ich da gemacht habe vorhand, ok, jetzt
passt das auch besser, ja was macht man da nachdem man den Preis festgelegt hat, da muss
man es ja irgendwie schließen, also muss man in ok, muss man schon ein Häkchen hin machen,
oder meinst du es sollte beim Klick einfach direkt angehen und dann kann man was angeben,
ah mal gucken, mal gucken, das kann man ja alles noch ändern, so, ok was wollte ich
jetzt machen, man klickt da drauf, dann klickt man das Notification und wenn man hier auf
ok klickt, wenn man auf ok klickt, dann macht ihr die Notification an und wenn man auf x
drückt, dann macht ihr die Notification aus, weil ich das nicht Toggle nennen kann, oder
wir machen das echt so, wie der Chat vorgeschlagen hat, wir machen das hier gar nicht rein, sondern
sagen bei jedem Klick, ich würde das x und h mit dem Glockenzeichen ersetzen, ok, ok
gucken wir mal, also sprich wir könnten auch so mal wenn man hier drauf klickt, dann Toggle
direkt, was genau hast du für Schmerzen, ah da fehlt ein Quote, einmal Quotes, ok Quote,
also das geht direkt an, es geht direkt an und dann kann man was hinzufügen, das ist
eigentlich auch ok oder, und dann klickt man irgendwo hin und es ist wieder weg, na das
ist doch eigentlich auch eine Möglichkeit, da kann man sich nämlich wirklich den Crab
hier unten eigentlich sparen, Maxpreis, wobei das eigentlich kleingeschrieben ist, das
checken die Leute wieder nicht, der Preistoggle ist sinnlos, warum, soll ich unten gleich
das Feld einblenden, äh ups, warte, soll ich gleich das Feld einblenden, für preis
größer als, dann machen wir hier Placeholder, Maxpreis, so dann weiß man Bescheid, wenn
man das hier eingibt, gut, warum ist da unten eigentlich so viel Platz, ich will da unten
gar nicht so viel Platz haben, kann man irgendwie sagen Dense oder so oder Flat oder so, dass
da weniger Platz braucht, ja wenn man jetzt, Slider, da muss man schon eine Zahl eingeben
oder ein Slider, Slider ist da glaube ich nicht so, ich meine vielleicht für Mobile
ist ein Slider doch gar nicht verkehrt, ein Slider für Mobile, mein den Slider ist da
ganz gut, ja ein Slider der mit UVPpreis startet, was soll denn Max sein, der lädt
immer noch Videos hoch, Slidermann hier am Start, oder kann man sogar, da könnte man
dann UVP oben drüber schreiben, exellent, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, Slidermann
ist am Start, das ist geil wenn man das zusammen macht, der Chat hat richtig gute Ideen, exquisite
Chat, guck mal hier das ist richtig cool, und starten wir jetzt, kann man da nicht bestimmen
was man da drauf schreibt, kann man da nicht bestimmen was man da drauf schreibt, Moment,
da man kann da ein Text reinschreiben, ne dann ist doof, ne da kommt es weg, also jetzt
kann man bestimmt sagen Max, Max ist da, Max ist keine Ahnung es doppelt vom UVP oder
so, und Min ist ja gut 1, oben drüber den Input, drüber noch den Input, das kann man
dann beinden irgendwie, bin immer noch nicht sicher wie wir das jetzt gescheit machen,
da oben können wir nämlich dann den Preis dran anzeigen lassen, das ist eine gute Idee,
das ist glaube ich für Mobile Crap auch nicht schlecht, übrigens wenn das schon durchgestrichen
ist, dann muss man beim deaktivieren eigentlich nicht nochmal aufmachen, also sprich wenn man
deaktiviert, wenn man deaktiviert muss das eigentlich nicht nochmal aufgehen, das reicht
wenn es beim aktivieren aufgeht, da muss ich mir noch ein bisschen Gedanken zu machen,
aber Leute es ist 22.10, ich gehe jetzt pennen, der Chat war wieder äußerst hilfreich, muss
man echt sagen, ohne Omega Lul, wenn du es bearbeiten willst, dann machst du einfach
aus und wieder an, ich meine den Preis nochmal setzen ist ja kein Ding, genau ich schreibe
den Chat ins Impresso, Amazon, Amazon ist exzellent, Amazon hat mein, oh, siehst du
deswegen, jetzt sind wir manchmal geploggt bei Amazon, ich bin kein Bot Amazon, ich bin
kein Bot, wir nehmen Amazon mal raus, wir nehmen Amazon mal raus
ich nehme Amazon echt mal raus, wir sind doch bei offener Amazon Seite, wir
müssen es ja nicht unnötig unbeliebt bei Amazon machen, aber im Web bleibt Amazon
natürlich drinnen, so, nice, der Chat war enorm hilfreich, sehr nice, bei anderen Sachen
auf die Marke, so die ganzen Sachen wäre ich sonst gar nicht gekommen ohne den Chat wahrscheinlich,
Bezos sperrt mich persönlich wahrscheinlich, ja, der guckt bestimmt gerade zu aus seiner
Villa aus, ich weiß gar nicht, wo der Typ wohnt und sagt, der Max, der muss gebannt
werden, the real auch noch, so Leute und denkt dran, Preis vergleichen und gucken ob Hardware
verfügbar ist, man preischämpt heutzutage, ich preischämpe jetzt nur noch, ich wollte
gucken, dass wir den Namen irgendwie etabliert kriegen, genau, preischämpt das mal, Reddit,
auf Reddit poste ich nix, Reddit suckt, Reddit lese ich nur ab und zu mal, alles klar Leute,
wir sehen uns, ich geh jetzt ins Bett, bis dann, see you.